this is a teach pendant and
traditionally it's how you teach a robot
arm to do something it's awkward two of
the problems with programming robots the
traditional way are that you need to
tell it exactly what you want it to do
point to point and the other is that the
robot assumes that nothing changes
so you just manually drive the tip of
the robot to where you know you need it
to go and then hit record and remember
that point then you drive it over to the
other place and hit record to remember
that point and then when you play it
just goes from one point to the next and
it can do that over and over and over
again in the event that there is some
error something moves the robot has no
way of knowing that the robot will still
go exactly where you told it to go the
first time and that can result in a
crash or breaking something or injuring
a person it's just like any computer it
will do exactly what you asked it to do
even if that's not what you meant in the
early days of computers writing code
generally meant using what's called
assembly language you would have to
literally tell the processor to move
things from one memory address to
another or to tweak some values or to
change specific pixels on the screen
like giving instructions to this arm you
would be telling the chip every single
thing that it had to do but as time
moved on program has got higher level
languages write some words and some
rackets the system works out the boring
details for you if you've ever worked
with a spreadsheet then that counts
writing a formula in Excel that's enough
in the end sure it all gets converted to
assembly language but most programmers
never even have to think about it the
team here at Autodesk spear 9 workshop
in San Francisco are working on more or
less the same thing just for making
physical things so basically the biggest
robot that we have in the lab which we
call ash is essentially a big robotic 3d
printer that's printing in stainless
steel so we have a MIG welder that is
depositing stainless steel onto a metal
plate and by activating the MIG welder
while moving the robot we're building a
weld bead and then we're building beads
on top of each other you would typically
use welding to stitch two pieces of
metal together what we're doing is
using the same technology but stacking
the metal on top in order to produce a
separate piece of finish material now
ultimately the result is the same the
motors in the robot arm are told moved
this way it's just the humans original
instructions are a bit more abstract and
they're filtered through another couple
of layers using a teach pendant would be
pretty impractical for these complex
curves normal 3d printers do basically
two and a half d like they go to an x
and y and then up and down this robot
can point in various directions the
robot needs to know not only where it is
but how it should point when it gets
there so we give it a piece of geometry
and the software figures out the
instruction set for the robot that will
result in a print that is what we want
one of the things we're developing is a
closed-loop feedback system where the
robot is actually aware of what it's
doing so before it completely fails a
print it's keeping track of the quality
of the print that it's doing and it will
actually correct reprogram itself in
real-time in order to avoid an actual
failure so what we're working on is a
vision system where between vision and a
couple of other sensors we can monitor
and supervise the status of the prints
so if the welder runs out of wire or
something else happens that the robot
would traditionally have no way of
knowing now the robot can know that not
all the robot's movements are being
directly controlled by a person and if
it goes wrong it's a bit different than
just having an error message pop up this
arm here weighs two tons and when it
wants to it moves fast
the only reasonable how this post is
because I'm literally holding the
emergency stop button in my hand just in
case our robot currently has no way of
sensing us and what currently happens is
when a person that shouldn't be near a
robot gets close to the robot you shut
everything down it would be great and
we're interested in a future where the
robot can know that that person is there
it's revision or some other kinds of
sensing and then actively avoid that
person and continue doing doing what
it's doing self-driving cars hospital
heart monitors basically everything
electronic ultimately the code in it is
just ones and zeros more levels of
abstraction between the programmer and
the bare metal the easier it is to write
code but when something goes wrong
fixing it
might be out of your hands thank you
very much to all the team at Autodesk
and to their applied research lab here
at Pier 9 in San Francisco go check out
their YouTube channel or pull down the
description for some links to see the
amazing projects they're working on
you